s
régions de la province.
Autrefois, on les appaelait
les gardes-chasses e
qui ont beaucoup évolué depuis
plus de 150 ans comme nous
l'explique Jacques Bissonnet.
♪ ♪ ♪
les Laurentides. Des agents
du ministère de la Chasseetetett
les chevreuils qui sont
menacés par les loups. s s s s x
à cette époque. Ils travaillent
nsnsns des conditions parfois
difficiles. Ils sont aussi mal
rémunérés, mais ce sont le plus
de la nature.
- (voix d'animatrice): L'énergie
des  o o o o o o o o o o o o o e
l'alimentait pas seulement
n n n n idéal.
- Un peu comme ces jeunes
qui sont allés en expédition
pour deteteteteteteteteteteteteé
cette pionnière, la première
dededede la province
à être nommée garde-chasse.
Dans les années 30, Maud Watt
voulait protéger les cartors
et aider les Autochtones.
- Avec la conservation
des castors, ils ont...
ils ont beaucoup plus.
Ils ont plus de nourriture.
- (voix animateur): Les orignaux
avaient épuisé les possibilités
nutritives de ce territoire,
du moins, pendant
les longs mois d'hiver.
- À cette époque,
gérer cette ressource, mais
on réalisait aussialalalalallait
donner de meilleures conditionsn
à ceux qui allaient faire t t t.
- Avoir illégaleme..............
- À l'école des gardes-chasses
de Québec, une nouvelle
formatio a a a a a a a a a a a s
sur l'importance de mettre
fin nnnnnnnnnnage.
En 1970, le gouvernement
adopte la Loi de la conservation
de la faune. La désignation des
gardes-chasses et gardes-pêches
des agents de conservation
de la faune.
PIERRE VALOIS, agent de
conservation de la faune
pour redorer l'image des agents
du service, puis aussi,
un peu, pour mieux exprimer
rvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvr)
- La Convention de la Baie James
est signée 1975.
ROBERT BOURASSA,ecececececececec
- ...et accorde aux Cris et
aux Inuits u r r r r r regard
sur les décisions touchant
la protection de
leurt t t t t t t t t t t t t te
par la suite pour offrir
rerererererere formation aux Cr,
Naskapis et Inuits du Nouveau-
Québec.
K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K ,
devient le premier agent
au
les droits exclusifs de chasse
et de pêche dans
privés sont abolis.
- Le gouvernement abolit
les 1 200 club
Toute une révolution.
Une mesure bien accueillie
par les citoyens.
- Oui, monsieur. C'est une très
bonne  l l l l l l l les gens
sont fiers de ça à part de ça.
- Un peu moins par les partisan.
- La formule n'est pas rodée...
On ne croit pas qu'elle puisse
mettre en place des structures
valables qui pourraient assu
de la forêt.
-  l l l l l l l l l l l l l l r
les parcs, ce qui lui donne
tatatatatatatatablir des parcs
de conservation et de récréation
où l'exploitation des ressourcee
de la Chasse et de la Pêche
- Contrairement avec c
du Québec ne peut pas,
de son propre chef, décider
de permettre l'exploitation
minière o a a a a a a a a a a ar
des parcs reconnus. Il va devoi.
puis je pense que c'est presque
historique ça, cette a
- Évidemment, c'estomomomomomom,
les parcs du Québec s'ouvrentà .
la création, en 1985, de
tatatatatatatatatablissements
de plein air du Québec,
la Sépaq, qui est un élément
de notre biodiversité.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, M